حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اضنه
وخبير الانشاءات والكوارث ورئيس منظمه
مياموتو للاغاثه والحد من مخاطر الزلازل
سيد مياموتو كان واضح اليوم ان الانهيارات
الكبيره المباني ليست فقط بسبب
الزلزال بل هناك
من يرى ان هناك شبهات غش في البناء انت
كيف ترى ذلك
الاخير
لقد
طلعنا على عدد كبير من المواقع هناك مباني
لم تنهر ايضا ما هو واضح بالنسبه الينا هو
انا معظم المباني التي انهارت هي مبنيه
قبل العام الفين
وكما
تحدث التقرير بنهايه التسعينيات 98 وتسعه
وتسعين كان هناك تغيير كبير في قانون
البناء اذا كل ما بني وشهد قبل العام 2000
لم يلتزم بهذه المعايير وبالتالي هو خطر
ولكن بعد ذلك اعتمد القانون التركي وهو
يتغير كل فتره وفتره ولكن بعد الالفين يجب
ان تكون المباني في امان ولكن بعد كل ما
رايناه
خلصنا ان الانهيارات حصلت للمباني التي
بنيت ما قبل الالف لكن هناك تقديرات بان 5
الى 10% من المباني المنهاره هي حديثه
وهذا يفاجئ ولكن
اذا راينا النظام يمكننا ان نفهم لماذا
اولا
ليس هناك استقلاليه للمهندسين المهندس
يكون موظفا او متعقدا لدى المقاول لكي
يشرف على البناء وهذا يكاد يكون تضارب
مصالح على المهندسه ان يكون مستقلا
وبالتالي هذا النظام يجب ان يتغير كذلك
المهندس ليس لديه او ليس هناك نظام لترخيص
المهندسين
وبالتالي الحصول على هكذا ترخيص امر مهم
يجب اعتماد هذا المنظومه ان معظم
المهندسين الان الذين يبنون في تركيا هم
بارعون انا لا اعتبرهم سيئين هناك تصميم
جيد بناء جيد ولكن تبقى هناك استثناء طبعا
انها تحصل الاخطاء وبسبب ذلك حصلت
الانهيارات طيب اذا نظرنا الى الخريطه
المناطق المتضرره
خاصه في انطاكيا كانت اكثر تضررا هل ترى
بان ذلك يعود الى
قوه الزلزال ام لطبيعه الارض ام بسبب عدم
التقيد
بمعايير البناء
في صينيه
زلازل التي
تحصل ربما المشكله في الارض في الجيولوجيا
في كيفيه انزلاق التربه الى ما هنالك
وانا الان في اضنه
هناك مثلا
مبنى انهار
ولكن من حوله قد لا تكون المباني متضرره
عاده يكون لديك مباني او مبنى واحد متضرر
او منهار المباني المحيطه متضرره ولكن
احيانا لا نرى هذا وبالتالي انا اتحدث عن
امور ربما تحصل طريقه غير طبيعيه وهذا ما
يفاجئنا ويدعون للتحقيق
هذا كله ما رده طبعا
رداءت المواد المستخدمه في البناء ماذا عن
قوه الزلزال
هناك من يرى بان قوات الزلزال لها تاثير
كمن يرى بان طبيعه الارض
وهناك من يقول كما ذكرت قبل قليل معايير
البناء ولكن
ايهما اشد ضررا من هذه الاسباب الثلاثه
عاده تكونوا مزيجا من هذه الاسباب بالنسبه
الى نظام البناء
يجب هو جيد ولهذا معظم المباني بقيت
في حال غير منهاره ولكن اذا كانت المباني
لم تحظى بي مواد جيده بهندسه جيده ولم يتم
الالتزام بالمعايير ما بعد العام 2000 حين
ذاك السبب يكون او بالاحرى تجتمع هذه
الاسباب وتسبب الانهيار جاء في خبر عاجل
قبل قليل للمرصد مرصد زلزاله تركيا يقول
هزار ارتداديه بقوه اربعه فاصله سبعه من
عشره مقياس ريختر في كهرباء مراش وتم
ايقاف مؤقت لاعمال الانقاذ قربه
مباني متدعيه واشكرك
ما يموتو الخبير في الكوارث هو رئيس منظمه
ميامه موتور
حد من مخاطر شكرا